what is up I told you last year DC runs
this [ __ ] EC runs Hall eggs and we're
bringing all this for you guys because
you're the fans or the guys we make
movies for we're going to kill it
let's bring them out yeah do it all
right we got some troublemakers for you
so so watch out Suicide Squad is in the
house
kotone turn Bukhara
now your turn
Slipknot Adam Beach
el Diablo cheer none Dez Captain
Boomerang Jai Courtney Wilson's out
there come on out come on out who's next
uh-oh Oh who's coming see now I got to
pronounce his name Otto always out here
triple-a triple-a all right let's bring
it
Viola Davis
Colonel Rick Flagg Joel Kinnaman
jared leto let's not share this is for
hard old wine
enchantress watch out this is the man
Scott Eastwood
margot robbie
harley quinn
and ladies and gentlemen Will Smith
all right let's get down to business
exciting David people say that you were
bringing a whole new look a whole new
feel to this genre what was your intent
was that your intent all along how'd you
go about doing it I grew up reading
comic books I've always been a fan of
the art that they are and I wanted to
make a film that looked like a comic
book and not just has to do with the
visuals of the film and sort of the
beauty of the medium and the costumes
and the Wardrobe in the sets but also
the characters I wanted these characters
to have as much soul as the characters I
remember as a kid growing up you know
it's yeah you guys are all and this
isn't a question for everybody so I like
that you're the height man that's right
yeah I'm very excited I'm just very
excited yeah this is really a question
for all of you but to me the genius of
this story is that you're bad guys and
the bad guys always have this incredible
attraction and yet now you're walking
this line of trying to do a good thing
that's going to be a lot of fun and
anyone can grab this one but the process
of being a bad guy what is the advantage
of a character who's supposed to be bad
trying to be good I think what was great
David said really early he said that
this is not a movie about good versus
evil this is a movie about bad versus
evil and I just thought that was a
really interesting distinction it's like
you know where where is the line between
bad and evil is there a point where
you've done so much dirt that you're no
longer redeemable you know and it's fun
for us trying to find that line of where
you do bad things but you do them for
good reasons and sometimes you don't you
just do it because it's fun to hurt
somebody you know so it's like it's
really it's really great walking that
line
I love you too call me now I got to see
I got to see the movie don't rub your
nipples sir it's disturbing
I got to see the movie about a week ago
it's fantastic I was blown away by it
one of the things that really caught my
attention is that you guys have a
chemistry that feels very real as a cast
it feels like you guys get along what
was that process like was that natural
that you hang out a lot did you train
together how did it work anyone it's
really unfortunate because nobody got
along I don't know but you know what was
really great the way that what I would
say David's superpower is is helping
actors fall into your characters and
your relationships he does a really
interesting extended rehearsal process
where you you you really don't realize
you're rehearsing you're kind of sitting
down and you're talking and he digs into
your life so we've all shared really you
know deep stories about ourselves and
our pains and our triumphs in in this
process and then what David does is on
set you know you thought he was being a
nice guy and you were sharing your life
and then in the middle of a scene he
throws your greatest childhood trauma
back at you and he says and dude the
Joker did it
you know it's a really fantastic process
where you you just can't help but but
bond when when you're sharing though
those kind of intimate stories with one
another I mean think about what you
share with your best friends you know
and how open you are and how emotionally
honest you are so if I can help these
guys create sort of an accelerated
friendship through this process of just
trusting each other knowing each other's
secrets you know that's what you're
seeing on screen and in the magic of
what these guys have done is how well
they've bonded as a family and I think
that's what's a little bit different
from this film than a lot of other films
is that that human connection they have
and the most important thing to me is is
performance and actors and these guys
killed it they bare their souls out
there yeah yeah for a lot of you there
was an incredible amount of training in
this film I mean physical hard training
you can see it in the film you guys are
an amazing shape but the scenes
themselves are very action fact what was
that like I mean how hard were you
working was it we work in full days were
you killing yourselves or go stick
Margot's yeah you take that way yeah
whatever everyone did in this film I
didn't a pair of heels so it kind of
added an element of difficulty there you
know it was really cool we got to do so
I mean David wanted us to do as many of
our stunts as possible we ended up doing
most of them ourselves and learning
random little skills I learned how to
hold my breath underwater for like five
minutes that was cool
we got to like jump off things things
always exploding on set I mean it was
just insane all the time I don't know
anyone else in the business right now
who would have both the stamina and the
will and the talent to to pull off with
Margo pulled off and when you see the
film you're going to see her doing her
own fighting her own stunts I mean yeah
we had a double but I think double is it
craft eat sandwiches I mean she really
active incredible work I want to just
get my own shout out to you buy a lot
viola I thought you were one
in the film you portray one of the most
tough minded characters I've ever seen
in a film it's really an incredible
performance yeah thank you yeah I played
myself then I'm very afraid I will never
master David music huge part of this
film I was blown away by how much
incredible songs were accessed for this
film what was how did you make those
choices a little bit for my own life
with just a lot of finding that right
combination of music that goes with a
picture because there's a true alchemy
that happens that when you can get the
right music on a fantastic piece of film
it transcends you know they both become
something else that's really magical and
obviously I got some guys in the show
that have a little experience in the
music world so I couldn't let them down
he didn't use that he didn't use that
though he didn't do that
that's that's what that's what I hear in
my head all the time
uh David before now we have a time we
are so tight on time to get to so many
people that we have time for one
question so we have a question here yeah
someone's coming up for the cast nieces
nephews sons and daughters how do they
feel about you having this role for mr.
Ayer three or post BBS thank you post
PBS up now this this is the type of
thing that you know no matter how cool
you you think you are your kids think
you suck so
this is the height this is like the
first time where like I'm cool for real
it's like the Suicide Squad I don't know
what it is but something about this idea
and something about this cast has really
captured something you know so my kids
are doing what I say at least for the
next couple of months but it's a really
good look and I want I want to share one
quick story one quick story so we
started the rehearsal process and Jared
was really the first person that like
really kicked it into another gear so we
were rehearsing and and you know so that
he was working separate so the Joker was
working separate so one day there's a
knock on the door and this guy walks in
this you know tough-looking guy walks in
he says I got a message from mr. J and I
was like yo man the [ __ ] security like
some dude just walked into rehearsal
right and he puts a box down on the
table in front of Margo and he says
that's a gift from mr. J in honor your
relationship right
how's that Oh mr. G Oh mr. J okay okay
so Margo you know starts to open the box
and you know there was a note and it was
like from the Joker and I was like oh
okay that's cool that that's funny jared
is like taking it real serious right
right and Margo opened the box and there
was a live rat in the box she jumped
yeah and then listen listen I was
playing dead shot but if I had had
pearls on I would have clutch them it
was like so in which I the top back off
with your rat right he stood for the
whole movie that's that's the kind of
stuff I was doing but he really kicked
everybody into another level and a nice
level of focus on doing this right
that's what I've been so impressed is
that you know Jarrod isn't does an
incredible contribution to the film
obviously you know the tightrope act of
playing the Joker who is the most well
known villain and Western fiction in
look you know he's standing in the
shadow of giants and the contribution
besides just nailing the role in being
so courageous and tackling it is is he's
the guy that really galvanized the cast
he was he was the sword you know that
were he was the hammer that made that
sword sharp I think that
now I I wish we had more time
go ahead Jared cut you off start now you
know if I open my mouth it may get a
little x-rated here
are you guys having fun so far this
weekend let me ask you a question what's
your favorite movie come on what's your
favorite movie
no no what's the favorite movie you're
gonna see on August 5th what was it I
can't hear you where is that well no
more promotion needed for that film
you